كنا نسير في المركز التجاري
وجاء إليه أحد معجبيه وكان مثل يا إلهي يا
فتى ، هل تعرف من هو والدك
وكنت كما لو كنت لا ، أنا مجرد
طفل صغير لا أعرف الكثير
[موسيقى]
أعلم أن الناس سيلاحظون هذا
الاسم على ظهره بغض النظر عن الاسم الموجود
في المقدمة ،
إنه شيء سيتبعني دائمًا
ولكن حان الوقت الآن بالنسبة لي لوضع طريقي الخاص
، أنا تيمويا وأنا  إلى الأمام
للمنتخب الوطني للرجال في الولايات المتحدة ، كان
[الموسيقى]
[الموسيقى
] أحد أفضل اللاعبين الذين لعبوا اللعبة على الإطلاق
، فقد فاز بجائزة أفضل لاعب في
العالم في العام ،
أناس يحبون يا إلهي طريقة والدك جورج
وسأكون هكذا  مثل
[موسيقى]
أتطلع إليه كثيرًا وأحترم
ذلك وأعمل بجد كل يوم لأحاول أن
أكون مثله تمامًا كما تعلم باتباع
خطواته وأعتقد أن هذا هو
هدفي الرئيسي
[تصفيق]